.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Geflüchtet vor dem Krieg der Ukraine,
über Polen
Richtung Küsnacht im Kanton Zürich.
Es sind krebskranke Kinder,
die medizinische Hilfe brauchen.
Wir sind wegen des Kriegs
u n d  der Behandlung hier.
Der Krieg
hat ihnen jede Sicherheit genommen.
Im stillgelegten Altersheim Sonnenhof
finden die Kinder und deren
Angehörigen Mitte März Unterschlupf.
Sie waren plötzlich in einem Krieg.
Für mich war völlig klar,
dass man nicht Nein sagen kann.
(Beide) Schere, Stein, Papier.
Anhelina ...
... Nazar ...
... und Denis:
Sie sind hier für unbestimmte Zeit.
Peppermint.
Als ich Ja sagte,
konnte ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass es für mich
praktisch zum Fulltime-Job wird.
Ich vermisse meinen Vater,
meine Tiere, mein Zuhause,
meine Spielsachen.
Unterkriegen lassen sich die Kinder
aber weder vom Krieg
noch von der Krankheit.
Er beklagt sich nie.
Natürlich will er nach Hause,
aber er versteht,
dass er hierbleiben muss.
Ja, wir sind stark.
Wir schaffen alles.
Ein Leben zwischen
medizinischer Versorgung und Heimweh,
davon handelt dieser Film.
Es ist Ostern:
Die rund 120 bunt zusammengewürfelten
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner
des Sonnenhofs sind im Bastelfieber.
Rund ein Monat ist vergangen
seit ihrer Ankunft.
Die siebenjährige Anhelina
mag Ostern und alles drum herum.
Willst du das?
Nimm es. Wähl etwas aus.
Ich will das hier.
Hast du ausgesucht?
Lass uns zum Tisch zurückgehen.
Los.
Oder ...
- Los, los, Anhelina.
Hast du ausgesucht?
Normalerweise bringt Papa Geschenke,
wir essen Ostergebäck
und Mama kocht etwas Leckeres.
Der Vater musste zu Hause bleiben,
sollte das Militär ihn brauchen.
Anhelina bleibt tapfer - wie so oft,
seit bei ihr vor drei Jahren
ein Gehirntumor entdeckt wurde.
Auf andere Gedanken kommen,
das tut ihr jedenfalls gut.
Die Kinder vermissen ihren Alltag.
Sie vermissen ihr Zuhause,
ihre Freunde.
Normalerweise
gehen sie in die Schule
und haben auch sonst viel los.
Deshalb sind wir dankbar,
dass die Leute diesen Event
für die Kinder organisiert haben.
Freiwillige Helferinnen
aus der Region
haben den heutigen Basteltag
organisiert.
Die Hilfsbereitschaft ist immens -
die Macht- und Sprachlosigkeit auch.
"Alltag" kehrt wieder ein
unter den Bewohnerinnen,
falls es so etwas
hier überhaupt gibt.
Jeder Tag ist anders,
aber immer voller Herausforderungen.
Lass uns
über den neuen Jungen sprechen,
der gestern angekommen ist.
Das Kinderspital Zürich
hat den Jungen hierher verlegt,
in die Obhut von Alexander Lüchinger.
Der 68-jährige Ingenieur hat
nach Kriegsbeginn schnell reagiert
und 24 krebskranken Kindern
zur Flucht verholfen.
Hello, nice to meet you.
Welcome.
Neu wird er sich auch um diese Mutter
und ihren Sohn kümmern.
Als Ingenieur hat er viele Projekte
in der Gegend von Schytomyr
realisiert - westlich von Kiew.
Die Menschen vor Ort
sind ihm ans Herz gewachsen.
Deshalb bot er an,
mit einem grossen Bus Freunde und
Bekannte in die Schweiz zu fahren.
Auf der Fahrt
zurück von der polnischen Grenze
kam eine Anfrage
bezüglich krebskranker Kinder.
Also
organisierte er einen weiteren Bus.
Wir fahren euch am Morgen
in die Augenklinik.
Wir müssen noch abklären,
ob ihr danach
wieder ins Kinderspital müsst.
Das ist noch unklar.
* Sie dolmetscht. *
Stopp. Moment.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
No.
- They don't have to?
Sie müssen nicht in die Augenklinik.
- Nicht in die Augenklinik?
Sie haben gleichzeitig einen Termin
im Kinderspital. Wussten wir das?
Did we know about that?
Ich weiss nichts über die Familie.
Das ist das Problem.
I'll go ... I'll give you a minute.
Can you talk to them?
Warte mal.
Wir haben momentan
ein bisschen ein Chaos.
Just a bit of chaos.
Es geht einfach ...
... viel durcheinander.
(Nachricht) Zurzeit
sind alle unsere Leitungen besetzt
oder Sie rufen
ausserhalb unserer Öffnungszeiten an.
Wenn alle verstehen,
dass nicht alles sofort richtig ist
und am Anfang
alles etwas mehr Zeit braucht -
und ich glaube, das tun alle -,
dann geht das gut.
Das geht gut -
mit dem nötigen Verständnis.
Und der Name des Kindes ist ...
Nazar.
Nazar Voloshyn.
Nazar ...
An das Warten müssen sich alle
Bewohner zwangsläufig gewöhnen.
Niemand weiss, wie es weitergeht.
Es ist Mitte Mai.
Ein Monat ist vergangen seit
Nazars Ankunft hier im Sonnenhof.
Man sieht
den elfjährigen Jungen selten,
die meiste Zeit
verbringt er auf seinem Zimmer.
Hier ruht er sich aus oder spielt -
ohne Freunde.
Zu gross ist die Ansteckungsgefahr.
Nazar hat einen Gehirntumor
und ist dadurch erblindet.
Er darf nichts riskieren.
Zum Glück hat es Lego im Sonnenhof.
Damit hat Nazar auch zu Hause
in Lemberg gerne gespielt.
Er beschwert sich nie.
Natürlich will er nach Hause,
aber er versteht,
dass er hierbleiben muss.
Er hatte medizinisch
gerade einen Rückfall,
aber es geht ihm gut.
Ja.
Ich mag es hier.
Die Langeweile
versucht Nazar zu verstecken.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ein ähnliches Schicksal
hat der achtjährige Denis.
Die beiden Buben sind fast gleich-
zeitig in den Sonnenhof gekommen.
Auch Denis hat einen Gehirntumor,
ist mittlerweile blind
und wird
von anderen Kindern abgeschottet.
Stopp.
Einen Vater hat Denis nicht mehr.
Er starb an einem Herzfehler.
Umso fürsorglicher
zeigt sich seine Mutter.
Wir gehen zum Rosmarin.
Der Hausmeister
darf uns nicht erwischen.
Aber nur berühren.
- Ein Blättchen.
Nein, nur so.
- Okay, riech daran.
Gut?
- Ja.
Hier ist noch etwas anderes.
Nimm die andere Hand.
Hier sind die Blätter.
Was ist es?
Riech.
* Sie sprechen ukrainisch. *
Keine Ahnung.
- Melisse.
Melisse. Glaubst du nicht?
Doch.
Hier hat es noch mehr.
Reib daran.
Was ist es?
- Pfefferminz.
Peppermint.
Mhm.
- Mhm, mhm.
Zu tun
gibt es für Denis ansonsten wenig.
Ist es schwierig hier?
Mhm.
Sag das doch etwas genauer.
- Ja.
Warum?
Es ist sehr langweilig.
Du verstehst die Sprache nicht,
oder?
Ja,
ich verstehe die Sprache nicht.
Aber du lernst sie.
Du lernst Englisch.
Ja, ich lerne Englisch.
Um die Ärzte zu verstehen, oder?
- Ja.
Ja.
Los, aufstehen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Stufe.
Zwei aufs Mal.
Ja, Denis und ich
fühlen uns hier sicher.
Aber meine Eltern
sind in der Ukraine.
Ich sehe auf dem Handy immer,
wenn der Sirenenalarm losgeht.
Deshalb bin ich immer beunruhigt
und kann mich hier nicht entspannen.
Unter anderen Umständen
würde ich die Schweiz
mit anderen Augen betrachten.
Aber so ...
Sorry.
Ja, Liebling?
Aber wir sind stark.
Wir schaffen alles.
Haben wir Kraft?
Zeig deine Muskeln!
Ja, wir sind stark.
Wir schaffen alles.
Alexander Lüchinger hat bei seiner
Planung wirklich an alles gedacht,
sogar an einen Hausarzt.
Arinna or Arina?
- Arina.
Arina.
Der pensionierte Didi Burkhardt
hat einst in Tadschikistan als Arzt
gearbeitet und dort Russisch gelernt.
Oh, oh, oh.
Putzt sie sich die Zähne?
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Viel Süsses.
* Er spricht russisch. *
Viel Schokolade.
Da war ein Nierentumor.
Man musste eine Niere rausnehmen.
Es gab auch eine Chemotherapie und
sie steht deswegen unter Kontrolle,
weil es eine Krebskrankheit ist.
Jetzt hat sie
eine normale Krankheit:
zu viel Süsses und kaputte Zähne.
Wie sagt man?
Danke.
Tschüss.
Arina. Poka.
Ein Zahnarzt wird das Mädchen
genauer anschauen müssen.
Eigentlich
ist es normales Doktorhandwerk,
das es hier braucht.
Ich glaube, es ist gut,
wenn das ganz normal sein kann.
Man ist im Heim und wenn etwas ist,
kann man zum Arzt.
Das wird nicht immer so sein, aber
bis sie richtig angekommen sind,
sollen sie wissen,
dass sie aufgenommen sind
und nicht im System verlorengehen.
Didi Burkhardt
ist für  a l l e  Sonnenhöfler da.
Für die Kinder mit Krebs
sind extra zwei Ärzte
und drei Pflegefachpersonen
aus der Ukraine mitgereist.
Eine Bedingung des Kinderspitals,
wo nämlich Personalmangel herrscht.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Die Kinder sollen einen möglichst
geregelten Alltag bekommen.
Es ist 8 Uhr morgens -
Zeit für die Schule.
Anhelina fühlt sich dafür
mittlerweile stark genug.
Sie hat in der Ukraine
die 2. Klasse besucht.
Sport und Lesen
waren ihre Lieblingsfächer.
Weil sie so gerne zur Schule ging,
hat sie
sogar Zusatzunterricht genommen.
Der Schulbus der Gemeinde
fährt die Kinder direkt
bis nach Erlenbach ins Schulhaus Erb.
Hier wurde eine Klasse
nur für Flüchtlingskinder geschaffen.
(Frau) Alle stehen auf.
# Guten Morgen, guten Morgen.
(Alle) # Good morning, good morning.
# Buongiorno.
# Privjet.
Salam aleikum.
- Salam aleikum.
Deutsch steht auf dem Plan.
"Heute ist ..."
Wer weiss,
was heute für ein Tag ist?
Pst. Hände hochstrecken.
Was ist heute für ein Tag?
Heute ... ist ...
- Heute ist ...
... Donnerstag.
- Heute ist Donnerstag.
Hey!
Nein, nein, nein,
das machen wir nicht.
Nazar, du musst sonst wegsitzen.
Komm.
Ja.
Du kannst hier vorne sitzen.
Nicht spucken.
Das machen wir nicht.
Es gibt Kinder,
die unser Alphabet gar nicht können.
Das lernen wir.
Andere können schon etwas Englisch
und kennen das Alphabet gut.
Die Herausforderung ist immer,
etwas zu individualisieren.
Einige Kinder
kriegen dann eine andere Arbeit
und andere werden lange an dem sein.
Anhelina ist auch hier in der Schweiz
eine fleissige Schülerin.
Sie will Archäologin werden.
Da kann man
interessante Dinge finden:
Kristalle, Gold ...
Und ich will Pyramiden entdecken.
Sie macht sich gut.
Sie ist eine der Jüngeren,
aber sie war von Anfang an dabei.
Ich glaube, sie arbeitet am Nach-
mittag auch viel mit ihrer Mutter.
Ich glaube, sie hat zu Hause
auch ein ukrainisches Programm,
mit dem sie die Sprache usw.
noch lernt.
Alle Kinder gehen raus.
Alle Pause.
Nach rund eineinhalb Stunden ist auf
beiden Seiten Durchatmen angesagt.
Anhelina hat in der Schweiz
mit ihrer neuen Freundin Ana
eine Verbündete gefunden.
Zusammen sind sie stark.
Uns schubst und ärgert niemand.
Die Schüler
haben keine Lust mehr auf Unterricht,
dabei steht eigentlich Mathematik an.
Nein.
* Sie singt die Töne vor. *
* Er ahmt sie nach. *
(Beide) Schere, Stein, Papier.
Schere, Stein, Papier.
Schere ...
- (Beide) ... Stein, Papier.
Schere, Stein, Papier.
Wir haben kein Lernziel.
Die Kinder müssen nirgends hin.
Ich muss
weder ein Zeugnis schreiben,
noch mich an den Lernplan 21 binden.
Ich versuche,
sie in unsere Welt zu integrieren
und sicherzustellen,
dass sie sich wohlfühlen
und die Grundregeln verstehen.
Sollte der Krieg andauern,
muss die Schule
die Lernziele wohl überdenken.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Auf Wiedersehen, Frau Duc.
- Auf Wiedersehen, Bogda.
- Auf Wiedersehen, Anhelina.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Nicht alle Sonnenhöfler haben das
Glück, in die Schule gehen zu können.
Denis
bekommt stattdessen Fernunterricht.
Und kommt dadurch öfter in den Genuss
der selbstgebackenen Torten
seiner Mama.
Die leidenschaftliche Bäckerin
hat sich extra
einen kleinen Ofen besorgt.
Wie findest du den Kuchen?
Schrecklich ... fein.
Denis und seine Mutter
sind sich in vielem ähnlich:
Humor ist ihre Waffe
gegen die Ungerechtigkeiten im Leben.
Und Erinnerungen
geben ihnen die Kraft weiterzumachen.
Hier sind alle Kinder
im Klassenzimmer.
Mmh.- Was hat die Lehrerin sich
für euch ausgedacht?
Du musstest die Tür öffnen
und dafür ein Schloss
oder den Schlüssel suchen.
Den Schlüssel.
- Den Schlüssel.
Liudmyla Petrivna hatte Pech.
Sie war diejenige,
die ausgeschlossen wurde.
Du hast sie quasi gerettet.
Ein wahrer Ritter.
Denis und Inna kommen aus Jaresky,
einem kleinen Dorf
im Osten der Ukraine.
Dort lebten sie mit
Denis' Grosseltern und drei Katzen
in einem Haus mit grossem Garten
und vielen Blumen.
Meine Eltern sind zu Hause.
Sie arbeiten auf dem Feld,
füllen das Lager für den Winter auf
und warten auf uns.
Wie Bären.
Wie Bären legen sie Vorräte an.
Denis' persönlicher Vorrat:
ein Pokémon.
Es ist Ende Juni.
Über drei Monate
sind seit ihrer Ankunft vergangen.
Heute bekommen die Sonnenhöfler
neue Möbel -
ein Geschenk
einer grossen Möbelkette.
Das bisherige Mobiliar
war nur geliehen,
einst als Übergangslösung gedacht.
Die Freude an der Arbeit ist grösser,
als der Wunsch
sich definitiv einzurichten.
Die Heimat ist woanders.
Und trotz Krieg machen sich immer
mehr Gedanken über eine Rückkehr.
Alle, die wie ich zurückwollen,
haben Angst,
v.a. um die Kinder.
Aber das Herz will, was es will.
Aus medizinischer Sicht wäre Anhelina
jedenfalls bereit für eine Rückkehr.
Der Tumor
hat seine Macht über sie verloren.
Ihr nächstes MRI
steht erst in zwei Jahren an.
Ungefähr ein Viertel der Leute hier
überlegt sich,
ob sie nach Hause gehen sollen.
Das sind Familien mit Kindern,
die momentan
keine Behandlungen mehr brauchen.
Ich habe ihnen gesagt,
dass ich in dieser Situation
nicht gehen würde.
Meine Beurteilung:
Es ist jetzt nicht sicherer
als damals, als der Krieg ausbrach.
Jetzt kriegen die Bewohner neue Möbel
und ein Viertel will nach Hause -
ist das nicht ein Widerspruch?
Nein, wir füllen das Haus
wieder mit anderen.
Es kommen auch laufend Neue.
Das Haus
wird deswegen nicht leer werden.
Die neuen Möbel
lösen kein Gefühl der Heimat aus.
Denis' Mutter sagt etwas ironisch,
als hätte sie Zweifel daran:
Ich weiss nicht.
Es sind schöne Möbel ...
Nice.
Auch Denis' und Innas Herzenswunsch
wäre die Rückkehr zur Familie.
Aber:
Wir gehen nicht nach Hause.
Wieso nicht?
Wir können die ...
... Therapie
dort im Spital nicht fortsetzen.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Treatment.
- Treatment?
The treatment in hospital.
Yes, we can't continue it.
Die Möbel werden gesponsert,
für den Rest kommen der Bund
und die Gemeinde auf.
* Hoffnungsvolle Klänge *
Mitte Juli.
Die ersten Bewohnerinnen
folgen ihrem Herzen.
In 20 Min.
geht es Richtung Busbahnhof
und von dort in das
noch immer vom Krieg dominierte Land.
* Hoffnungsvolle Klänge *
Ich weiss nicht. Ich mag es hier.
Aber ich will so gerne heim.
Ich mag alles hier
und will nicht weg.
Aber wir vermissen unsere Verwandten
so sehr.
Aus einst fremden Menschen
sind in den vergangenen Monaten
Verbündete geworden.
Ich bin traurig
und glücklich zugleich.
Sie dürfen nach Hause
in die Ukraine.
Das ist der Wunsch von uns allen.
Es ist ein gutes Zeichen,
dass die Kinder nach Hause gehen.
Das ist ein Zeichen dafür,
dass sie sich als gesund empfinden.
Und dass die Ärzte ...
- Ist das wirklich so?
Ja, sie haben sich
im Kinderspital rückversichert,
ob sie mit ihren Kindern
gehen können.
Ich glaube, dass die Kinder erst in
einem Jahr wieder zum Arzt müssen.
Seit vier Monaten
ist Alexander Lüchinger
eine Art Ersatzgrossvater
für die Kinder.
Also ...
Ich lasse sie nicht gerne gehen.
Aber irgendwie bin ich froh,
dass sie gehen können.
Aber andererseits
ist es auch schade.
Ich habe versprochen,
dass ich sie besuchen werde.
Werden Sie Ihr Versprechen halten?
- Vielleicht nicht ganz alle.
Aber die aus der Gegend Schytomyr
werde ich besuchen.
Das ist klar. Ja.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Für die Zurückbleibenden
geht das Leben in der Schweiz
mit all den Arztbesuchen weiter.
Die Behandlungskosten dafür
übernimmt die Krankenkasse.
Denis bekommt zum wiederholten Mal
im Kinderspital eine Chemotherapie.
Seine Blutwerte
sind zurzeit vielversprechend.
Wir hoffen, der Tumor wächst
nicht mehr oder wird sogar kleiner,
sodass er
keine Therapie mehr braucht.
Die Behandlung
dauert insgesamt sechs Monate.
Nach drei Monaten
hat er eine Kontrolluntersuchung.
Bis dahin bleiben wir sicher hier.
Wir werden sehen,
wie sich der Tumor entwickelt.
Falls der Arzt uns dann gehen lässt,
werden wir mit Freude
in die Ukraine zurückkehren.
(Ärztin) Yeah, that's perfect.
Denis ist sich mit seinen acht Jahren
solche Untersuchungen
bereits gewöhnt.
The first one is the big one here.
Seine Krebsdiagnose
hat er vor bald fünf Jahren erhalten.
That's okay.
Hallo,
mein Name ist Michael Grotzer.
Ich bin der ärztliche Direktor.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Wie geht es Denis?
Gut, einigermassen.
- Okay.
Isst er?
- Yes.
Kein Fieber, keine Schmerzen.
Kann er rumlaufen? And talk?
- Yes.
Michael Grotzer wurde von Anfang an
in Alexander Lüchingers
Fluchtplan miteinbezogen.
Er und sein Team beraten die
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner nun auch,
wenn es um deren Rückkehrpläne geht.
Okay. Tschau.
- Tschau. Tschau.
Tschau.
- Tschau.
Okay.
Thank you.
Man hat natürlich
immer gemischte Gefühle.
Man fühlt sich verantwortlich ...
... für ihre Gesundheit
und ihr Wohlbefinden,
aber ich verstehe auch,
dass die Situation der Familien
hier nicht perfekt ist.
Ihre Familien
sind noch im Heimatland.
Das spielt eine grosse Rolle
für die psychoemotionale Gesundheit
dieser Kinder.
(Ärztin) So.
Done. Finito.
Okay?
- We will go.
Flüchten wir.
- Flüchten wir?
Let's go.
- "Let's go."
* Musik aus dem Handy *
Mit Hintergrundmusik.
Die Kappe.
Bye.
Thank you. Bye.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Die nächste Abreise steht an.
Das Okay vom Kinderspital
hat Anhelina bekommen.
Die Situation in ihrer Heimat
aber ist immer noch prekär.
Natürlich haben wir einen Plan B.
Wenn die Situation
sich verschlechtert,
werden wir der Kinder wegen
die Ukraine wieder verlassen.
Ich habe keine Angst.
Ich will nur zu meinem Papa,
in unser Haus, zu meinen Verwandten.
Wow!
Three?
- Three.
In rund 20 Min.
holt sie und ihre beiden Töchter
ein privates Busunternehmen ab.
Wo man ... ähm ...
hochgehen kann ...
* Sie sprechen ukrainisch. *
(Frau) Es hat elf ... äh ... zwei.
Zw...
Zwölf?
- Zwölf, ja.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Vira war
eine der wichtigsten Frauen hier,
weil sie ganz viel gemacht hat.
Sie hat z.B. für alle gewaschen.
Warum weiss ich allerdings nicht.
Sie hat für alle gewaschen,
fürs ganze Haus.
Sie war Coiffeur
und hat ihnen die Nägel gemacht.
Sie hat einfach alles gemacht.
Anscheinend haben sie die Aufgaben
nun auf andere verteilt.
Ich hoffe, es geht gut weiter.
Aber sie ist ein grosser Verlust.
Wir werden sie anrufen.
Wenn wir etwas nicht verstehen,
holen wir sie aus dem Bett.
Sie wird keine ruhige Minute haben.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Vira, ich muss los.
Yes.
- Yes. Goodbye.
Wo hast du das Glöcklein?
Das kleine Glöcklein?
* Sie sprechen ukrainisch. *
Ist okay.
Pass auf dich auf. Und alles Gute.
Und vielen, vielen Dank.
Goodbye.
Wenn ich nächstes Mal nach Schytomyr
komme, besuche ich euch.
Yes. Yes.
- With Ana.
Okay. Take care. Bye-bye.
- Bye.
Grüsse an deine Frau.
- (Frau) Greet your wife.
Ich werde es ihr sagen.
Ja. Thank you. Bye-bye, Vira.
- Bye.
* Sie sprechen ukrainisch. *
No.
Ich habe ihr ein kleines Glöcklein
geschenkt, ein Glücksglöcklein.
Tschau, Vira. Bye-bye.
- Bye. Bye.
Okay. Schönen Abend.
Bye-bye.
- Bye.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Und wieder warten.
Die angesagten 20 Min.
werden zu viereinhalb Stunden.
Der Bus hat vorher
noch andere Rückkehrer abgeholt.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Vira und ihre beiden Kinder
suchen ihr Glück nun wieder
in der Heimat bei ihren Liebsten.
Für die restlichen Sonnenhöfler
geht das Warten weiter -
auf unbestimmte Zeit.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022